لا مش عندي انا لسه انا كده اهو
ايوه
اوكي تمام
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم
اتمنى تكونوا في احسن حال جميعا طبعا في
البدايه بنقدم خالص تعازينا
ودعائنا بالرحمه لكل من فقدوا ارواحهم فيه
زلزال شرق المتوسط وتحديدا سوريا وتركيا
ودعاء النبي ان ربنا يخفف ويشفي المرضى
والجرحى
انا في انتظار اسئله حضراتكم
[موسيقى]
مساء الخيرات احمد ابو سمره هذا اول تعليق
مساء الخيرات يا استاذ احمد
اخونا جاي رائد العتيبي هل هناك خلاف
سعودي مصري وان وجد ما هي الاسباب اتمنى
ما تتجاهل السؤال والله مبره طويله في طرق
اللي بتدير بها الدول العربيه الخلاف عاده
بيكون في خلاف بيتم ادارته عن طريق
الاعلام تستطيع ان تعلم بامان بدقه شديده
اذا كان هناك خلاف في الدول العربيه بين
بعضها البعض من وسائل الاعلام لان وسائل
الاعلام في بلدنا للاسف الشديد لا تتحرك
بحريتها يعني لكن انا حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تصلني معلومات مدققه عن اسباب الخلاف
استاذنك ان انا ارجئ الحديث عنها حين
تتوفر لي معلومات كفايه عندي اطراف عن
رؤوس عناوين انما ما عنديش
يعني معلومات مدققه على الموضوع وانصر
تتوفر لي سوف اخبركم السلام عليكم
ده اخونا احمد مساء الخير على الجميع اهلا
وسهلا الغريبه ان التقارب بين مصر وايران
ايام محمد مرسي وزياره مرسي لايران وزياره
نجاد لمصر ومجيئه الى الازهر وفتح باب
السياحه ومنها
واهمها السياحه الدائره البلدين يجد لم
يجد اي اعتراض غربي
طيب ومش فاهم السؤال هو ليه يجب اعتراض
غربي على اساس ان هي ايراني يعني ما هي
ايران لها علاقات مع دول يعني على حسب
الفتره الزمنيه ايران مش
ارانب طول عمرها دوله معزوله وكلمه معزوله
برضو فيها مبالغه يعني ما هي عندها علاقات
مع دول اخرى كثيره
هو الغريب مش انه علاقتهم بمصر لما يقعدوا
علي اعتراض
الغريب انه الموقف المصري فيما يتعلق موقف
السياسه الخارجيه فيما يتعلق بايران يصعب
فهمه على يعني على الاقل انا بالنسبه لي
ربنا انا صحفي مصري يعني
لبنان الى اين
[موسيقى]
نتمنى الها خير يعني لبنان في مازق عنيف
وبعدين اصله المشاكل اللي من نوعيه لبنان
ما هي مشكله لبنان موجوده في ليبيا
وموجوده في دول اخرى
زي مثلا
زي الى حد ما اليمن بس اليمن وضعها مختلف
الغريبه جدا انه دايما الدول اللي عندها
حكومات مستقره بتعاني
لانه المشاكل كثيره التحديات الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والبيئيه كثيره تخيل انه مشكله
البلد بادئه ان ما فيش حكومه مش قادرين
يعملوا حكومه فالمسافه بعيده جدا يعني
[موسيقى]
هل هناك المساله الايرانيه مالها المساله
الايرانيه استاذ احمد السلام عليكم
انت بتحاول تفكرني بحاجه انا افتكرت
الاستاذ احمد ابو سمره اللي هو الاخ اللي
كان بعتلي او الصديق اللي كان بعت لي سؤال
عن مساله ايران وبالمناسبه وانا قلت ان
انا قلت له فكرني وانا هجاوبه
هو وجهه نظر الاستاذ احمد انه بيقول اذا
كنت اتذكر وارجو ان تصححني بيقول لي انه
انا عنده نظريه انه ايران ليست عدوه لا
لاسرائيل ولا للولايات المتحده وانه
لو كانوا هم اعداء لقامه اسرائيل بدعم
امريكي بتصفيه مثلا برنامجها النووي فلما
قلت له ان البرنامج النووي يعني صعب
تصفيته الان قال ما هم ما صفوهوش ليه من
الاول مكان عندهم الفرصه عشان سؤالك ده
انا عملت حلقتين
مع شخصيه مهمه
السفير رفعت الانصاري ويستفيد رفعت
الانصاري هو دبلوماسي مصري نعم ولكن هو
عنده تجربه كبيره جدا في مجال الاستخبارات
والامن وهو نفسه يعني شارك في عمليات ضد
اسرائيل وله قصه عجيبه غريبه
وكتبت في كتاب وتستحق يعني لمغامرات كتيره
في اسرائيل يعني هو في اسرائيل لكن ضد
اسرائيل
هتذاع ان شاء الله في الويك اند لكن
الاجابه بالاضافه للي هيقدمه السفير رفعت
الانصاري القصه باختصار ان هم فعلا فشلوا
انت مش قادر تصدق ان اسرائيل وامريكا او
هكذا سؤالك يوحي ان هم ممكن يفشلوا في
اجهاض طموحات دول من دول العالم الثالث
عاوز اذكرك ان فشلهم في توقع وبالتالي
اجهاض البرنامج النووي لم يقتصر على ايران
المثل البارز جدا على فكره الصين مثال
بارز لانه ما كانش حد عاوز الصين لا
الولايات المتحده والغرب ولا الاتحاد
السوفيتي بس دي سبقت في الستينات
المثال القوي جدا ولا هدي لك مثل باكستان
لان باكستان كان في نوع من التوافق غضب
عدم رغبه بس بما انه ايران بما ان الهند
اصبح لديها برنامج نووي فكان في نوع من
التقبل ان لازم تكون عدوتها عندها نوع من
القوه الردع يعني مش راضيين بس يعني
متفهمين لكن المثل اللي كان واضح قوي
واللي كان ضد رغبه كل دول العالم وخصوصا
الغرب كانت كوريا الشماليه فالمساله يعني
فشل من الغرب فشل من اسرائيل في ان هم
يعرفوا ان الناس دي كانت بتطور برنامج
النووي متقدم في غفله منهم يعني اتمنى
اكون اجاوبت اسالك والحلقتين فيهم اجابه
اوضح على سؤال حضرتك
السلام عليكم
الغريب ماشي
سيد جبيل انا مروان من المغرب اتابعك منذ
سنوات وانا حقا احترمك وقد ساعدتني جدا في
دراستي للعلوم السياسيه سيد جبيل اصبح
اغلب الشعوب
العربيه حتى المنفتحه منها متشدد جدا في
افكارها متعاطفه مع الحركه
الرساله لم تكمل انا اشكرك عموما على على
يعني رسالتك الطيبه ومستني رساله تكمل
استاذ صوتك مو واضح هل صوتي مش واضح يا
ماندو
طب ممكن الان واضح يا اخونا ممكن يكون
عندك المشكله لو حد اخر شايف ان الصوت مش
واضح من فضلكم اكتبوا
حد كتب ان الصوت مش واضح
طيب نريد حلقه عن اقتصاد العراق في اقرب
فرصه باذن الله مساء الخير عبد الله مساء
الخير اتمنى الصوت يكون واضح لا في حد
تاني بيقول الصوت مش واضح يا ماندو
نعم
مساء الخيرات يا غالي ربنا يخليك
انا اعتقد ان المشكله مش في المايك
مرحبا سيد جبيل الله يحفظك ادهم السلام
عليكم
حبيبنا جبيل بنحبك جدا الله يحفظك علاء
عبد الله اسماعيل انترناشونال مروكو ترافل
اوكي
اشرقت ربنا يخليك يا عبده اشكرك مساء
الخيرات مساء الخير مساء الخير
عبد الله بيقول الفيديو بيعلق مش متاكد ما
اعتقدش في الاول بس تحيه لك استاذي من
سوريا صوت خلاص كده عظيم جدا استاذي
الكريم ما هو مصير الاقتصاد العالمي في ظل
ارتفاعات الفائده ما هو ده النقطه السؤال
اللي بيقولوا عليه الوان مليان مليان
السؤال اللي يسوي مليون دولار ده المثل
بيقول كده بس هو يساوي اكتر من مليون
دولار كتير يعني انه
الاقتصادات الكبيره عندها تضخم ارتفاع
كبير في الاسعار
استقر المينستريم او المدارس
السائده في الاقتصاد في العالم من 30 سنه
واربعين سنه وجدت انه لما يكون عندك تضخم
يعني ارتفاع في الاسعار وعندك ركود اللي
هو بيسموه الركود التضخمي وهي ظاهره لا
تتكرر كثيرا
ركز اهم حاجه على التضخم ابدا بالتضخم
وحاربه مهما كانت التكلفه حتى لو ادى ذلك
الى انك تقعد الناس في البيوت وانك توقف
النشاط الاقتصادي لانك انت لما هتحاربه
ازاي انك هترفع التضخم هتحاربه ازاي بانك
انت للاسف هترفع الفايده
هتحاربوا بانك تسحب السيوله من ايديل
الناس بطرق مختلفه معنى ذلك ان انت بتحاول
تعطل النشاط الاقتصادي على امل انه التضخم
الطلب يقل وارتفاع الاسعار يتراجع لانه
القناعه عند تيار كبير من الاقتصاديين ان
ما فيش اسوا من انه المواطنين يفقدوا
الثقه في عملتهم فاذا فاز قد الثقه في
عملتهم طبعا انا بقول الكلام ده وبتكلم في
ذهن الدول المتقدمه لان الدول الناميه
طبعا بتمر بتجارب عنيفه جدا في ان عملتها
بتتدهور بشكل مرعب ما فيش اسوا من ان
الواحد يفقد القيمه الثقه في عملته
وبالتالي اذا فقد الثقه في عملته في
قدرتها الشرائيه ده هيؤدي الى سلسله يعني
من الاحداث المؤسفه جدا للاقتصاد الناس
هتتحاول تتخلى عن العمله يحاولوا بسرعه
يتخلوا عنها بان هم يروحوا لعملات اخرى او
ذهب او اصول او يروحوا يشتروا يعني
مستلزمات مختلفه اذا كانت يعني احتياجاتهم
الضروريه وغير الضروريه والعقارات والذهب
وغيره وبالتالي
ده هيؤدي ان العمله تضعف اكتر ويؤدي الى
التضخم يزيد لان بقى في اقبال متزايد ان
الناس بتشتري حاجات لا يحتاجونها الان
لمجرد
ان هم خايفين الامور تغلى غدا وبالتالي
العالم دلوقتي
البنوك المركزيه الكبيره رغم كل التطمينات
ان احنا مش هنواجه ركود عنيف الا ان كله
مركز على التضخم ولا تبدو علامات على ان
التضخم سوف ينتهي خلال شهور سوف يعيش معنا
لشهور على الاقل في 23
والخلاف كله بقى هل الاجراءات اللي
بتعمليها بتعملها البنوك المركزيه دي وعلى
راسها الفيدرالي الامريكي هتادي الى ما
يسمى بالصف تايلاندي يعني ان احنا نخلص من
التضخم بس لا نعاني من ركود
بشع ولا لا
وده خلاف
ايه اسباب
اسباب توتر العلاقات بين مصر والسعوديه
قاعدتكم والله انا فعلا يعني لم تتوفر لي
معلومات
اطمئن ان انا بقولها ان هي سليمه 100%
واعدكم ان انا اعرف ان انا هقول لكم بنفس
الشفافيه يعني طبعا انا عارف زي كل الناس
كل ما كتب يعني الكلام العام بس انا لا
اطمئن اليه لازم اتوثق انه من مصادر تكون
اكثر
يعني عشان اتكلم على هذه الخلافات بس
يقينا في خلافات
جزاكم الله خيرا اخي مشكور على الحياديه
المطلقه يفتقدها اغلب الاعلابيين اشكرك
محمد
اشكرك تبدو علامه يعني طيبه ترحاب انت
حاطط اشكال لطيفه كده اللهم كن بعون اهلنا
واخوتنا في سوريا وتركيا مشاهد وصور صادمه
عندك حق تامر ربنا يخفف عنهم
السلام عليكم سؤالي استاذ عن تقنين
المساعدات الخارجيه لمصر والحديث عن رغبه
الخليج بتقليل تدخل الجيش في الاقتصاد ما
هو ده هو الشائع هذا هو سبب الخلاف انا لا
اعلم
انما ده الشائع اللي بيقولوا للناس وانا
لما بقول احتك اتيقن يعني اعرف معلومات
خلاف الكلام اللي هو يعني في المطلق كده
هو حكايه يعني هي الخلافات بين مصر
والخليج بتثور على نفس تقريبا بنفس
الوتيره دي كل عده سنوات وبتاخد دايما
الشكل ده بيكون في سبب
خلاف
يعلموا المسؤولين وراء الكواليس الخلاف ده
بيتم تسريبه للاعلام ويتم خوض الخلاف
يعني
التعبير عنه من خلال وسائل الاعلام وليس
من خلال القنوات الرسميه ثم يهدا الخلاف
ويطلع المسؤولين يقولوا انه هذا كلام لا
يعبر عنه
وتاتي زياره مثلا انت بتتكلم على مصر
والسعوديه رئيس المصري السعوديه او ولي
العهد يزور مصر وبعدين يعني قبلات واحضان
وسلامات
ثم تنتهي الخلافات او التراشق بين
الصحفيين وتعود للمياه الى مجاريها في
حاجه انا تهمني ما اعرفش ما تهمش كل الناس
انا بيهمني في المشهد ده الصحفيين لان
بعضهم الحقيقه بيحط نفسه في موضع يعني
محرج جدا
يعني
مش عارف اقول ايه دول هم برضو كتير منهم
زملاء ولكن يعني يعني حاجه صعبه حاجه
بصراحه لا تستحق الاحترام انك تكون مجرد
النهارده
تشتم دوله وباقصع يعني باشد الكلمات وفي
اليوم التاني تعبر عن
مشاعر الاخوه ولا كلام لا يصح ابدا حتى لو
حصل خلاف حتى لو انت عاوز تهاجم حكومه
دوله ما يجب ان الكلام يكون منضبط وما
يخلفش مرارات يعني الكلام اللي احنا
بنشوفه والمتبادل واللي بيطول شعوب وده
يقول له انت كنت ايه وانت كنت ايه والكلام
يعني ايه
كلام مخجل
السلام عليكم استاذي
[موسيقى]
تقنيه انت بتسال تاني على تقنير المساعدات
المساعدات مش بتبقى عاوزه تقنين المفروض
ان الدول كل الدول بتدي لدول اخرى مساعدات
هي بتديها مساعدات لانها مستفيده اذا ما
كانتش مستفيده فلا يجب ان تعطيها
المساعدات ببساطه يعني يعني السعوديه لم
اعطت باكستان مساعدات هل اعطتها فقط من
قبيل اللي تشارت يعني ما هي مستفيده منه
هل لما اعطت مساعدات في شكل ودائع لتركيا
هل هي برضو مجرد اتشالتي واحسان مثلا
هل لم اعطت لبنان لسنوات طويله هل ده مجرد
اتشالتي واحسان المساعدات مشكوره من دوله
لاخرى ما بتكلمش على السعوديه ومصر على اي
دولتين السعوديه ومصر كذلك يعني ليس
استثناء المفروض ان الدوله اللي عندها
فائض بتساعد الدوله اذا كان ذلك يصب في
مصلحتها ازاي يصب فيه مصلحتها ان استقرار
الدوله دي اللي بتتلقى المساعده اذا اهتز
هتتاثر مصالح هذه الدوله ان الدوله اللي
بتدي المساعدات ديت لا تريد ان ترى فوضى
في هذه الدوله كل اللي بتتلقى المساعدات
تتلقى مساعدات اقتصاديه ولكن تقدم
اشكال اخرى من الدعم للدوله التي تعطي
المساعدات يعني هي امريكا بتدي مساعدات
لدول كثيره هل كلها تشارتي
فالمساله مش تقنين كل دوله بتشوف مصالحها
فين وبتعمله وللانصاف يعني انه احيانا
الثقافه العربيه بتبقى مختلفه يعني في دول
عربيه ممكن تكون مصلحتها مثلا انه لبنان
مصر تونس زي مثلا الا يهتز فممكن تعطي
مساعدات ولتكن مليون لكن هي الثقافه
والطبيعه العربيه انه في نوع من المنح
بكرم ممكن يعطي اكثر
كل
الحلا يعني
كردوخ كردي يعني اشكرك استاذي العزيز مساء
الخير استاذ سيد انت وعدتني بحلقه بعنوان
ماذا اه والله انت احمد رقيه
انا ممكن علشان انا وعدتك انا اقول لك انا
ليه بتاخر في الوعد اولا ان انا احيانا
بتبقى مثلا انا قلت لك السبب قبل كده ان
انا الفكره اكتملت فيها ذهني انا بفكر
فيها من اربع سنين ولكن
الفكره مش لاقي سبب يعني خايف ان انا اطلع
واقول كده ماذا لو حكم
الاسلاميين ما عادش غير طالبان مثلا يعني
انما انا عشان انا وعدتك انا هقول لك على
خلاصه الفكره وبرضو فكره الحلقه هتكون
قائمه ان شاء الله وطبعا لما بيكون موضوع
ملوش سبب مباشر دايما الاحداث بتضعوا
جانبا يعني عاوز اتكلم على الموضوع ده
النهارده فهتيجي مثلا زلزال تركيا وسوريا
يجي موضوع البالون الصيني يجي كده يعني
يجي الخلاف السعودي المصري
انما انا خلاصه ما توصلت اليه
ويعني ببحث اعتقد انه خد وقت طويل انه اذا
حكم الاسلاميون ايا كان توجههم دوله ما
فاحنا قدام اتنين من سيناريوهين اما نجد
دوله مدنيه علمانيه خالص لكن مجرد فيها
امور بتعبر عن الثقافه الاسلاميه يعني
دوله ما فيش فيها خمور مثلا الناس بترتدي
فيها
مثلا تفعيل مؤسسات الزكاه كده يعني
مفيش فيها حاجات ترفضها الشريعه بشكل فك
او جمهور يعني الاجماع الاسلامي على حاجه
كبيره يعني ما فيش فيها مخالفات فجاء
للشرائع الاسلاميه او القوانين الاسلاميه
لكن هتبقى دوله عاديه يعني زيها زي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه دوله اسلاميه
مثلا هل انت لما هل في في السياسه
الخارجيه مثلا السعوديه او حتى السياسه
الداخليه اختلافات عنيفه جدا عن المملكه
المغربيه مثلا ما فيش المملكه المغربيه
فيها جزء يعتبر جزء من شرعيه النظام
الملكي قائم على جزء منه ديني انه الاسره
العلويه ولكن بقطع النظر عن كده هي دوله
مدنيه عاديه
او ان احنا نلاقي نفسنا قدام حكم فيوقراط
يعني حكم ديني بيحكمنا الفقهاء وده
السيناريو خطير جدا بقى يمكن السناريو ده
قريب الى حد كبير في
ايران بس ايران دوله لها وضع شويه يمكن
المذهب يمكن الظروف بتخليهم برجماتيين جدا
انما هتكون فيوقراطيه زي نظام ايران كده
وزي التجربه السعوديه من 200 سنه ومن 300
سنه او يعني على الاقل من عشرات السنوات
اللي مضت انه انت في الاخر بتوضع كل شيء
قدام فقيه وطبعا الفقيه ده مش واحد بس ده
مجموعه من الفقهاء وهؤلاء الفقهاء
بينقلوا الراي للحاكم وكالعاده بيحصل
التزاوج ما بين الحاكم وما بين
وما بين رجال الدين وهم بيختاروا الاراء
اللي اللي تناسبهم يعني مثلا في امثله لا
تقع تحت حصر لما كان الحكام العرب مثلا
يرغبوا في شن حروب على اسرائيل كان
العلماء اللي هم بيقولوا انه لا يتصالح
ولا سلام مع اسرائيل هي اللي كفتهم بتعلق
لما كان بيبقى في رغبه من بعض الحكام
العرب انه نتصالح بتجد ان كافه العلماء
اللي هم بيقولوا الصلح والسلام هي اللي
بتغلب
وفي النهايه لان دي الونج ستوري يعني لا
يوجد نظام مميز يختلف كامل في الاسلام في
حدود ما وصلت اليه يختلف بمعنى انه له
خصائص واضحه في اعتبارات اخلاقيه ماشي في
[موسيقى]
يعني خصائص ثقافيه ما هو اليهود عندهم
خصائص ثقافيه والهندوس
والبوذيين وهكذا لكن فكره ان في اقتصاد
اسلامي يختلف مثلا عن اقتصاد السوق لا ما
فيش وما اعرفش ان في حد قال ان فيه ان حد
جاد يعني هل في نظام اسلامي بمعنى انه في
شكل معين من اشكال السلطه السياسيه لا
مفيش والتاريخ بيقول كده يعني الطريقه
اللي حكم بها تم اختيار بيها مثلا ابو بكر
تختلف عن عمر عن عثمان عن علي عن الخلافات
المختلفه لا يوجد نظام محدد
هذه الاجابه اتمنى ان هي تكون يعني وصلت
لحضرتك وان شاء الله نخصص لها برضو الحلقه
في اقرب فرصه
ماذا تعرف عن مش عارف اقرا الكلمه هل
تتوقع ان يكون رئيس امريكا القادم
باحد المرشحين لا اعلم عنه شيئا ده مارك
جونز لا اعلم
هل صحيح كما يقال ان هناك انهيار بالجيش
الاوكراني وهي بدايه النهايه احنا بنسمع
كلام كتير لكن اللي انا متاكد منه كالاتي
اللي هو الكلام الرسمي انهم يواجدون يجدون
صعوبات وانه الرئيس الاوكراني يتحدث عن
ذلك كثيرا
وانه الجيش الروسي
بيعتقد انه الوقت مناسب
انه يحقق اكبر قدر ممكن من التقدم حتى ولو
بخسائر كبيره قبل
ان تكتمل صفوف الجيش الاوكراني باسلحته
الجديده وبالتالي يبدو ان هناك تقدم وان
كان بطيئا وبخسائر كبيره من جانب الجيش
الروسي على حساب الاوكران لكن ما زال
اتسيرلي على الحكم على الامور
انا اعتقد مساله اوكرانيا دي
اذا صارت المساله بالوتيره اللي هي
الاصرار الروسي على تحقيق الاهداف اللي هي
معناها انهاء دوله اوكرانيا او يعني
انتزاع معظم الاراضي الاوكرانيه لصالح
روسيا واصرار الغلب الغرب على عدم
الاستسلام ان احنا هنكون قدام سيناريو شبه
جزيره كوريا مره تانيه
شبه جزيره كوريا في الخمسينات كانت شبه
جزيره واحده لكن نتيجه الخلافات الكبيره
جدا الشمالي اللي بيدعموا الكتله الشرقيه
للاتحاد السوفيتي والصين والكتله والجنوب
اللي بيدعموا الغرب بقياده الولايات
المتحده انتهينا ان احنا بقى عندنا
اتنين كوريا ليس مستبعد جدا ان يكون لدينا
اثنين اوكرانيا اوكرانيا الروسيه
واوكرانيا الغربيه
مساء الخير ما رايح حضرتك في طرح 32 شركه
في البورصه اسلام والله انا احنا اتكلمنا
عن القصه ديت واكثر مندهشت اليه ان انا
لما كتبنا انه البورصه سوف ترتفع رغم
الاقتصاد
الماذون في مصر الناس بيقولوا ده انت بعض
التعليقات ان ده تلميع يعني مش عارف بلمع
مين الحلقه او الفكره بتقول انه الاقتصاد
المصري ماذون
عنده ازمه وعلشان يكون عنده ازمه هو محتاج
يتبع مجموعه من الخطوات واحده من الخطوات
ديت انه يضعف عملته واحده من الخطوات ديت
انه الدوله تبيع بعض الشركات لما هي تبيع
بعد الشركات هدفها ان هي تحصل على نقد فتح
تحل نقص الدولار الذي لديها فما فيش حد
بيقول ان ده معناه ان دي علامه جيده انما
هيترتب عليه ان من يستثمر في البورصه سوف
يربح ادي المساله لانه هيشتري اصل جيد بعض
هذه الاصول جيد وجيد جدا هيشتريه بسعر
منخفض جدا ليه سعر منخفض لان البورصه
المصريه كانت يعني وصلت الى البطن تقريبا
الى يعني نقاط متدنيه جدا والخصوصا لو كان
اجنبي هيجي يشتري الحاجه اللي كان
بيشتريها
الدولار كان ب 15 جنيه هيشتري دلوقتي
دولار بقى ب 30 يعني فقد الجنيه حوالي 50%
نصفه
هل هذا اننا يعني انا بعتبر يعني انا
بنوصف الكلام واخونا الاستاذ هاني
الاقتصاد المحترم بيوصف الكلام فانت
بتسالني ايه رايك ايه رايي ان اللي
هيدخلوا البورصه قطعا سوف يستفيدوا
خصوصا اذا كان يعني عنده
مدخراته بعمله اخرى غير الجنيه المصري
وحتى المصريين لانه هيدخل هيشتري اصول
منخفضه على الارجح سوف تعلو هل ده حاجه
جيده للاقتصاد الاقتصاد توافقوا على انه
هناك ازمه وهناك طرق للخروج منها دي واحده
منها هل هذا هو الحل المثالي لا مش الحل
المثالي الحل المثالي ان الاقتصاد يخرج من
كواته ويبتدي كل الحكومه اللي موجوده انها
تراجع كل نقاط الضعف وتدور على نقاط
انطلاق تخلي تعظم بها الانتاج وبالتالي
الصادرات وتقلل الواردات وده كلام بنقوله
كل يوم
الله الله يكون في عون اخوتنا في سوريا
وتركيا امين يا رب ان شاء الله لماذا
تركيا تمنع دخول المساعدات لشمال سوريا
انا ما اعرفش ان هم بيمنعوا دخول
المساعدات انا عارف ان الخلاف القديم
كالاتي انت عندك الحكومه السوريه وعندك
منطقه حكم الذاتي او الاداره الذاتيه اللي
يعني اليد العليا فيها للكورد وعندك
المناطق اللي هي شمال غرب اللي هي ميلي
تحت حكم تركيا
بالاضافه طبعا الى مناطق النفوذ او يعني
النفوذ اللي بتمارسه تركيا امريكا
كل دوله عاوزه المساعدات الخارجيه التي
تاتي باذن وقرار الامم المتحده ياتي عن
طريقها لما ياتي عن طريقها ده معناه ان
دعم
لشرعيتها على الاراضي السوريه يعني لما
يجي عن طريق تركيا يبقى ان هي بتقر الامم
المتحده كل الدول بتقول ان تركيا صاحبه حق
او لها شرعيه او ده بيدعمها بس الاهم من
كل ده ان هي لما تكون في ايديها المساعدات
سوف تعطي احبائها حلفائها وتمنع هذه
المساعدات عن
[موسيقى]
السوريين الواقعين تحت
السلطات الاخرى تحت قصد مثلا تحت بشار
وبالتالي تضعفهم وهم كذلك مش عاوزين
المساعدات تذهب
تاتي عن طريق تركيا علشان
يمنعوها عن الناس اللي عايشين تحت
الاحتلال التركي او تحت النفود التركي
وبالتالي يضعفه الاتراك فهي حرب يعني حرب
ومساعدات زي ما بيقولوا
هل ممكن يكسر حصار قيصر بسبب الزلزال حتى
الان لا هو الاخوان عبد الله بيتكلم على
ان قانون قيصر يعني ان الولايات المتحده
عملت قانون بتعقب فيه كل من يقترب من او
يتعامل مع النظام امريكا بتقول انا مش
يعني انا مش يعني المساعدات ليست ممنوعه
اتفضلوا وانا نفسي اقدم مساعدات لكن هي
نفسها مش عاوز تتعامل مع الحكومه فانا مش
هنزل المساعدات للحكومه طب هتروح فين الحل
الوحيد ان هي تيجي عن طريق معبر واحد
رئيسي اللي هو باب الهواء ايش معنى باب
الهواء كان في معابر كثيره لكن المعابر
التانيه الكتيره ديت اغلقت بسبب الصراع ما
بين روسيا والصين من جانب هي روسيا تحديدا
وبتدعمها الصين اللي بيقولوا ان كل
المساعدات يجب ان تاتي عن طريق دمشق بشار
الاسد لان ده حالفهم
والدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده عاوزين
المساعدات تذهب ولكن عن غير نظام الاسد
استقر المساله في النهايه ان في معبر واحد
اللي هو ممكن ياتي خارج سلطه الاسد اللي
هو باب الهوى وباب الهوى الان اصبح
لغايه امبارح يعني واظن ما فيش جديد
النهارده
غير قادر على ان تمروا منه اي مساعدات
لانه الطرق الرئيسيه او الطريق الرئيسي
الذي يقود اليه دمر بحكم الزلزال فانت
عندك يعني في شمال غرب المناطق الواقعه في
هذه المنطقه على الاقل حوالي اربعه ونص
مليون سوري في ظروف بالغه السوء وما
عندهمش اي منفذ ممكن تاتي منه مساعدات
ربنا يخليك الله يحفظك شكرا يا اخونا علاء
حلقات وعدتنا بها سيد المشتقات الماليه
اليمين اليسار
صح والله الوعود تطاردك لازم طالما تقول
وعد لازم بالنسبه للمشتقات الماليه حاضر
اليمين واليسار انا اجبت عليك سؤال وبرضو
حاضر
هل اخونا فارس بيقول هلا للباقي الطائره
حقيقيه انا ما اعرفش الاطباق الطائره
حقيقيه بس في حلقه لو حضرتك
دخلت على قناه نعرف وكتبت الاطباق الطائره
هتلاقي في حلقه انا بزلت فيها جهد جيد
يعني خد مني وقت طويل واصلت الظاهره كلها
مين قال ومين لا والتفسير ممكن يكون ايه
لكن انت بتسالني يعني انا طبعا في الاخر
يعني انا بحترم عباره ممكن اكون خطا فانا
افضل اقول انه كل ما قيل في المساله
الاطباق الطائره ديت انه الغالبيه العظمى
من العلماء
بيسخروا من الفكره ديت وبيقولوا ان
الاطباق الطائره ليست الا مشاهدات لاشياء
الناس ما كانتش عارفه ان هي موجوده منها
البالون بالمناسبه او المنطاد يعني مثلا
اهم حادثه اللي هي في يونيو سنه 47 اللي
هي جنب مدينه روزوال
هي كان عباره الحكومه الامريكيه الناس
قالوا ده طبق طائر الحكومه الامريكيه قالت
يا جماعه ده كان منطاد واحنا كنا بنراقب
تجارب نوويه في السر واتحطم جنب مدينه
روزويل او قروه قريه روزويل في نيومتسكو
اطباق درونز
بناطيد خدع بصري الى اخره انما في مجموعه
صغيره جدا
من العلماء والسياسيين بيقولوا والله شفنا
ودائما في مساحه رماديه كده
بتخلي الاخبار
او القصه اللي من النوع دوت قائمه دايما
هتلاقي عالم اتنين لكن الغالبيه بيقولوا
هذا كلام غير صحيح
على الاقل لو كان صحيح فهو ليس مؤثر في
حياتنا زي الجن والعفاريت تسمع ناس كثيره
يقول لك انا شفته وعملت كويس
فانت لن تغير قناعه هؤلاء لكن المؤكد
كانوا موجودين او غير موجودين هم مش
مؤثرين في حياتنا
او هكذا اعتقد يعني انا بتكلم عن نفسي هل
الزلزال سيكون ذريعه لاعاده نظام بشار الى
القمه العربيه ده بقى هو الموضوع اللي انا
ان شاء الله اذا ربنا احيانا انا بسجله
بكره صباحا كنت عاوز اسجله النهارده ولكن
لم تسمح الظروف
لانه انا لقيت ان انتم مهتمين بيه جدا
ولكن اهم من موضوع القمه العربيه يا
صديقنا هو الزلزال ده
طبعا له اضرار اقتصاديه وليه اضرار بشريه
خطيره جدا ولكن سوف يكون له تبعات سياسيه
كبيره جدا في تركيا وفي سوريا يعني في
النظامين اللي موجودين وقد تنزاح الاثار
الى دول اخرى ربما هذا الزلزال وطريقه
التعامل معه سوف تحدد مصير الرئيس التركي
اردوغان الاثار اللي هتنجم عن هذا الزلزال
ربما تحدد مصير الرئيس السوري اللي هو في
وضع حرج جدا
كان هو عنده مشاكل بالغه والناس دلوقتي
كان عنده مشاكل بالغه قبل يوم سته قلقان
المشاكل اصعب بكثير والعجز وقله الحيله
واضحه من الحكومه السريه وبالتالي طبعا
اردوغان وضعه افضل لكنه التوقعات منه اكبر
بكثير وبالتالي طريقه التعامل مع الزلزال
[موسيقى]
والتبعات يعني لهذه الماساه يكون لها اثار
سياسيه خطيره منها على سبيل المثال لغايه
ما نتكلم في الحلقه انه مثلا كل ما قيل عن
التقرب بين بشار واردوغان لم يعد اولويه
منه ان مساله عمليه عسكريه في شمال سوريا
لم تعد اولويه بالنسبه لاردوغان امور
كثيره سوف تتغير
هو مش يعني حكايه انه بشار يعود لجامعه
الدول العربيه المشكله مرتبطه بدول منها
مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه بتعتبر ان
بشار ليس الا يعني
[موسيقى]
ليس الا يعتبروه مندوب لايران وايران هي
العدو الرئيسي للسعوديه طوال الوقت حمى
والدول اللي هي بتحمل نفس وجهه النظر ديت
او الدول التي لا تريد ان تغضب السعوديه
بيعملوا فيتو على عوده بشار الاسد مره
اخرى للقمه العربيه
مساء الخير لو سمحت عايز رايك في خفض
تصنيف مصر
ما هو ده احد اثار الازمه الاقتصاديه
التصنيف الائتماني بيحدد جدارتك الائتميه
وقدرتك على سند الديون فلما يخفض جدارتك
الائتمانيه وفي حلقه بالمناسبه على نعرف
اقتصاد على التصنيفات الائتمانيه يا ريت
ترجعوا لها لما يتخفض جدارتك الائتمانيه
معناها انه مودس او اي مؤسسه اخرى بتقول
وفقا لتقدراتي ان الدوله ديت قدرتها على
السداد يا اما ممتازه يا اما جيده جدا يا
جيده يا ضعيفه الى اخره كلما قل تصنيفك
الائتماني يمتنع الناس عن اقراضك او بمعنى
اصح مش بيمتنعوا بقى بيقرضوك ولكن بفائده
مرتفعه جدا لان بيبقى هذا الاقراض استثمار
فيه مخاطره والاستثمار اللي فيه مخاطره
بيكون مقابله ارباح كثيره
بيقول البث يقطع البث بيقطع يا ماندو
طيب
استاذ العراق الى اين العراق هيفضل تعبان
ويعاني طالما انه بشكل المنطقه لم تحل
وشكل المنطقه بالنسبه للعراق وهي حسم
مساله ايران لتقدير يعني
[موسيقى]
الاسئله كتير
معلش انا يعني جريت بس هرجع للاسئله تاني
ما هو وضع العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
تلميحات للغرب للتسويه ده ما فيش تلميحات
ولا حاجه ده الكلام
من الاول تجد يعني رسائل متناقده ما هو
الغرب من الاول وما زال بيقول احنا عاوزين
سلام بس هم تصورهم للسلام ده
اللي هو صوت الولايات المتحده اللي
بتتبناه دول معينه في الاتحاد الاوروبي او
في النيتو اللي هي دول البلقان تحديدا
وتلاته دول الصغيره دي انا اقصد يعني
صغيره هي صغيره يعني كمساحه وكسكان مش
مؤثره قوي في الاتحاد الاوروبي وما هياش
غنيه
بولندا اللي هم الاكثر تشددا تجاه روسيا
وطبعا معاهم الحكومه الاوكرانيه ومعاهم
الولايات المتحده دول هم الاكثر تشددا
يعني وبريطانيا برضو دول الاكثر تشددا
ودول شايفين ان السلام لن يتحقق الا
بهزيمه روسيا فرص تقولهم اذا كنت هزمتها
من حقها سلام ايه يعني قصدكم استسلام يعني
فيعني يعني هو لا يعني احنا عندنا اعتقاد
دايما ان الولايات المتحده عارفه هي تعمل
ايه ودول اوروبا
خصوصا الدول الكبيره بتخطط وبتعمل انا مش
شايف الحياه ان المساله على هذا النحو
احنا من قدام اكتر من امريكا وليس امريكا
واحده يعني توجهات مختلفه ودي مش اول ازمه
يكون فيها توجهات مختلفه ومش عيب بس بيكون
في وضوح رؤيه
انا شايف انه القصه يعني وخاصه بالنسبه
لاوروبا يعني يمكن امريكا العمليه مش
اولويه كبيره ليها لانها بتتضرر من
الناحيه وبتستفيد من ناحيه والخلاف هي
بتستفيد اكتر ولا بتتضرر اكتر لكن بالنسبه
لاوروبا هي خاسر صافي على الارجح
وهم مش قادرين ما عندهمش القدره ان هم
يبرولوا رؤيه واللي عنده رؤيه متبلوره في
ضروره التفاوض مع الروس عاجز عن تنفيذها
اتكلمنا عن الجوانب العسكريه بدل الطغيان
الاقتصادي على المحتوى السياسي اتكلمنا عن
الجوانب العسكريه بدل الطغيان الاقتصادي
على المحتوى السياسي بتاعك وعن ازاي دول
زي ايران وتركيا واسرائيل
صناعتها العسكريه قويه والمصريه لا ولو
موجوده مصريه
فهي من التصدير انا يعني يا محمد انا انا
يعني يعني
اقول ليه ليه تركيا واسرائيل وايران نجحت
ومصر ما نجحتش يعني انا هي مصر عندها
صناعه عسكريه تقصد ان معندهاش صناعه
عسكريه بحجم الصناعه التركيه ولا
الاسرائيليه ولا التركيه طيب ماشي ما ده
مفهوم السبب ما هو السر يا محمد الصراعات
العسكريه مش مختلفه عن اي صناعه اخرى في
العالم انت علشان تصنع الالم ده او
الموبايل ده او التكييف ده الى اخره انت
بتتكلم على مجموعه حاجات كل الناس تعرفها
بتبدا بتعليم متطور تعليم يكون جيد
قاعده فنيه قاعده صناعيه عندك
بتستثمر كثيرا يعني بتثابر كتير لانه
الصناعه عامله زي الطفل
انت بيبقى عندك مصانع المصانع ديت بتبقى
هشه قدام الصناعات الاخرى اللي جايه لك من
الدول الاخرى بتحطها في حضانه بانك انت
بتحميها لفتره ما طبعا مش طول الابد والا
يعني كده ما فيش منافسه يعني وقصه طويله
يعني عاوزه علم عاوزه عاوزه منظومه كامله
كتير وما فيش دوله صناعيه بتبقى فاشله في
حاجات تانيه ما دمت انت قدرت تنجح صناعيا
فانت قطعا مش ممكن تكون فاشل في التعليم
ولا فاشل في
الاقتصاد ولا فشل في حاجه بس في دول عندها
اولويه يعني مثلا دوله زي روسيا دوله زي
ايران اللي انت بتسال عليه كانت اولوياتها
في ان هي تحط قدراتها
التصنيعيه في السلاح بحكم ظروفها لو كانت
الظروف دي مش موجوده وكنت ممكن تلاقي
سياره تركي ممكن تلاقي منتجات اخرى تركيه
يعني
بس انت سؤالك هجومي ليه طب يعني وبعدين
اشمعنى مصر يعني هي القناه دي انا مصري اه
وبفتخر الحمد لله لكن انا بقول عادي يعني
هي القناه مش العدد المصريين زي ما قلت
لحضرتك اللي بيتابعوا القناه يعني نسبه مش
كبيره قوي يعني فالشمعنا مصري يعني
نريد حلقه عن منطقه الساحل والصراع الدولي
منطقه الساحل في افريقيا ان شاء الله في
اقرب فرصه حاضر السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
عتبان عليك
عجباني عليك
صار لك زمان ما اتكلمت عنه
ما تنباك لمستقبل الوضع في سوريا والنظام
الاسد
ليه في فتره في الشهر اللي فات كانت
الحلقه اللي ليه اردوغان دي اخونا
اختنا مش عارفه اقرا الاسم معلش سامحيني
بس انا شايف
احنا من اقل من اربع اسابيع كان في حلقه
كامله كبيره عن سبب اسرار اردوغان على
على المصالحه مع سوريا انت حضرتك بتسالي
على الاوضاع ومستقبل سوريا الاوضاع في
سوريا وسامحيني ارجو ان انا ربنا ان شاء
الله يخلف ظني بس انا ما بتكلمش ما لم تكن
لله مشيئه اخرى الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في
سوريا كانت قبل سته فبراير الحالي صعبه
جدا تتكلمي على دولار بيساوي تقريبا 7000
ليره وصلحي لي لو كنت انا غلطان يعني
بتتكلم على متوسط رواتب تعادل يعني
بالدولار
بسبب انهيار العمله حوالي 15 دولار لموظف
الحكومه بنتكلم على حوالي من 70 الى 90%
على حسب التقديرات وسنه احصائها يحتاجون
الى مساعدات من السوريين بنتكلم حوالي 15
مليون محتاجين مساعدات نتكلم على بنيه
تحتيه
مخربه هتحتاج عشرات المليارات وعشرات
السنين
وسوريا الاهم ما فيها اللي هي العقول
ابنائها اللي عندهم قدره هجروها وعودتهم
صعبه
فاحنا بنتكلم على وضع صعب جدا
ساء وزاد صعوبه بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر
فانا
مش قادر اشوف حل يعني غير انه على المدى
الطويل وانه ان يكون في توافق دولي الاول
على مساعده السوريين على تجاوز مشاكلهم
اي ساحل تقصد انا
سلام عليكم
الاستاذ الفاضل الرائع ربنا يخليك شكرا
جزيلا لوجودك هل تتوقع تغييراتا قريبه في
المشهد السياسي الاقتصادي لدول المنطقه
العربيه في ظل الاحداث الاخيره ومنها
الزلزال وتغير سعر الصرف هم سؤالين
مختلفين الزلزال هيكون مؤثر على تركيا
ومؤثر على
سوريا ممكن طبعا يكون لي اثار على دول
الجوار وخصوصا
لبنان والاردن
انما بالنسبه لتغير سعر الصرف انت بتتكلم
على الدول اللي تم فيها خفض سعر الصرف
وبالتالي
خفض سعر الصرف لوحده مش هو المشكله انه
لكن المشكله ان تحرير سعر الصرف في الدول
اللي هي الناميه معناها خفضه بشكل كبير
لان عندها مشاكل كبيره عادات للمشاكل ديت
ما بتتحلش بشكل جذري بخفض قرار سعر الصرف
لان الدول دي غالبا ما عندهاش حاجات كتيره
تصدرها لكن هي بتضطر لخفض سعر الصرف والا
لن يسمح صندوق النقد باقراضها واذا ما
سمحش الصندوق النقدي باقراضها فهي لن
تستطيع ان تقترب من اي مصدر اخر وبالتالي
يعني الدول اللي خفضت سعر الصرف هي عندها
مشاكل اقتصاديه طبعا مش كلهم بنفس
يعني الدرجه من السوق ولكن هم عندهم متاعب
في دولات تقدر تتجاوز متاعبها وفي دول قد
لا تتجاوز متاعبها طب الدول اللي تتجاوزت
متاعبها تبقى عامله ازاي ما احنا شفنا
مثال على سبيل المثال في الدول الناس مش
حاسه بيها ما تونس
وضعها صعب وضعها صعب جدا يعني بس في الاخر
في حكومه يعني في رئيس حتى لو في ناس مش
راضيه عنه في شرطه حتى لو كان الاداء مش
عظيم في نشاط اقتصادي وان كان متراجع لكن
في بقى حاجات
في دول غنيه تقدر تتحمل الانقسامات ديت زي
ليبيا يعني الوضع سيء لكن لانه في نفط
كتير وفي غاز كتير فالناس مش محتاجه تشتغل
تقريبا يعني
لكن ردا على سؤالك اه طبعا وفي حلقه انه
موجوده في اول
عندي على القناه نعرف العاديه يعني اول ما
طلعت الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه وكانت
خلاصتها يعني انه
الازمه ديت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تفاقم من ازمه الغذاء ومستوى المعيشه
وتؤدي الى اضطرابات اجتماعيه وبالتالي
التغيرات سياسيه في دول كتيره حوالين
العالم
شكرا لك يا استاذ سيد لماذا تم لماذا تعد
قراراته الامم المتحده غير ملزمه يا ريت
لو تعمل حلقه نفهم منظومه الامم المتحده
ومجلس الامن اللي هي هي العمليه بسيطه
خالص انت عندك الامم المتحده ديت هي اللي
بتضم ال 193 دوله اللي موجودين في العالم
193 دوله
كدول اعضاء
لما انت عندك قرارات الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده وعندك قرارات مجلس الامن اللي هو
15 عضو منهم الخمسه الاعضاء طيب
القرارات مجلس الامن ممكن تبقى ملزمه لان
خصوصا وممكن تستخدم القوه
الملزمه وممكن تستخدم القوه لتنفيذها اذا
صدرت تحت البند السابع ده نظام الامم
المتحده لكن قرارات الجمعيه العامه 193
دوله بتبقى قرارات بتعبر عن مواقف يعني
يقول لك مين يدين روسيا مثلا ويطالبه
بالانسحاب فترفع الاغلبيه قد ايهم بس خلاص
ما فيش قرارات ملزمه امتى القرار يلزم لو
صدر من مجلس الامن معنى ذلك ان ما فيش ولا
فيتو من الدول الخمسه يبقى في الحاله ديت
العالم بهذا القرار ملزم ان هو ينفزه
هل في كل مره قررت مجلس الامن بتنفذ لا
لازم تكون صادره تحت اللي هو البند السابع
اللي بيخول لدول مجلس الامن لاستخدام
القوه طبعا ما فيش لا يعقل مثلا انه الدول
المجلس هيتخذوا قرار ضد روسيا يستخدموا
فيه القوه اولا لانه روسيا تعطلوا الفيتو
ثانيا مش معقوله هيفرضوا على دوله ما هو
مثلا كوريا الشماليه مش في دول الاعضاء
اللي هي عندها حق الفيتو ولكن عندها دوله
عندها سلاح نووي وبالتالي مستحيل يعني انه
ان حد
يعني هيستخدم القوه ضدها الا اذا كان
بيفكر فيه صراعين طويل
بس المساله على هذا النحو مش عارف اذا كنت
ساعدتك ولا لخبطتك يعني لو مش واضح قل لي
وانا اعيده تاني حاضر
اي ساحل تقصد انا بستنتج انه على السؤال
اللي انا قلته دول الساحل اللي هي بنتكلم
على مالي وبنتكلم على تشاد وبنتكلم على
النيجر وبنتكلم على بوركينا فاسو الى اخره
يعني دي هي بسموها دول الساحل
وهتلاقيه دايما تحت دول يعني شمال افريقيا
يعني تحت المغرب الجزائر ليبيا كده يعني
متابعك مدين
متابعك متابعك يسعد مساك استاذ سيد لماذا
اوقفت مصر اجراءات نقل تيران وصنافير الى
السياده السعوديه هل تنظر الامارات الى
السعوديه كمنافس لها في المنطقه يجب
اضعافه باي شكل السؤال التاني اسهل من
السؤال يعني اسهل من السؤال الاولاني طبعا
في حلقه عن تيران وصنافير معموله من عده
شهور ممكن ترجعوا لها مساله عدم النقل
برضو ما هو ده مرتبط بالعلاقات السعوديه
الاسرائيليه اللي انا للاسف السعوديه
المصريه اللي انا مش قادر اتوثق او عشان
اكون امين يعني انا كنت مشغول بقضايا اخرى
ما كانش منها من اولويات يعني ان انا ابحث
قوي في اسباب الخلاف لكن هي تيران وصنافير
مش مش مساله سعوديه مصريه فقط دي بتدخل
فيها الولايات المتحده وبتدخل فيها
اسرائيل على اعتبار ان وضع الطيران
وصنافير كان جزءا من اتفاق السلام بين
اسرائيل ومصر وبالتالي اي وضع نهائي
للتيران وصنافير لازم اسرائيل تكون موافقه
عليه ولازم المتحده التي كانت ضامنه
لاتفاقيه السلام تكون موافقه يبقى الاطراف
مصر
اسرائيل الولايات المتحده وطبعا الجهه
اللي هي بتطالب بالجزر اللي هي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه فانا بتسالني لماذا
طماطل او لماذا ايه لماذا اوقفت احتاج الى
التيقن مره اخرى ده جزء من السؤال اللي
طرحته في اول الحلقه هل هناك خلاف سعودي
مصري او ما هي طباعه الخلاف ان شاء الله
اول ما يعني ابقى عارف المعلومه اكلمكم
فيها باذن الله
انما السؤال التاني اسهل كتير الامارات
والسعوديه ايوه طبعا السعوديه بعد ما غيرت
سياستها الاخيره وبقت عاوزه يبقى عندها
سياحه رياضيه وعندها تبقى مقر بيزنس هب في
منطقه الخليج وعاوزه تبقى يعني عاوزه تبقى
تنافس على كل الصعد سياحه فن تجاره عاوز
تنوع اقتصادها في كل المجالات اصبحت
الامارات بتعتبرها منافس
وانت بتقول ايه عاوز يجب اضعافهم لا يعني
يعني التعبير المناسب ان الدوله بتنافس
يعني انت النهارده لما تكون اسبانيا
بتنافس فرنسا في السياحه معناه ان هي يعني
هتزرع عملاء هناك علشان تضعفها لا منافسه
يعني ده مفهوم الناس بتتعايش مع نفسها
يعني
انما تتمنى طبعا ان هي تكون تاخد منها كل
الشركات تتمنى تاخد منها كل السياح تتمنى
وهكذا والعكس سليم وده مش غلط يعني
في ظل الوضع الحالي للشرق الاوسط اخونا
محمد خليل
كيف تراه بعد عشر سنوات حسب توقعاتك
تحياتي لك
ولمندو من عرب 48
حمل بيسلم عليك يا صديقي
والله يعني عشر سنين ده احنا انا عاوز
اقول لك على قصه لطيفه في صحفي امريكي انا
مش متاكد اذا كان عايش ربنا يدي له الصحه
واذا كان توفى انا ما تواصلتش معه مثلا من
حوالي سنه او اكتر شويه اسمه توم فنتن
ممكن تبحث عنه هو من الجيل الكبير يعني
يعني في منتصف التمرينات ولكن افتكر ان
انا التقيته يعني اخر مرتين قابلته وبعد
كده التليفونات كانت مره في الاردن ومره
في المغرب 2010 2011 وهو غطى الشرق الاوسط
لسنوات طويله جدا انا اقول لك ليه بحكي
القصه الطويله دي ردا على سؤالك فبقول له
بعد السنين دي كلها يعني
ازاي انت يعني الحاجه اللي ممكن تلخص بها
تجربتك في الشرق الاوسط قال لي بدون تردد
يعني ما استناش قال لي لا يمكن توقع اي
حدث كبير في منطقه الشرق الاوسط واداني
بسرعه كده قال لي انا كنت بغطي الاحداث في
ايران وانا وغيري من الصحافيين بنغطيها
ولم نرى الثوره رغم ان كان في غضب كبير في
الشارع الايراني وكنا على الجبهه وبنراقب
الاحداث في 73 ولم نرى حربا من جانب مصر
وسوريا على اسرائيل
الكلام ده كان بيقولهولي 2010 وانا كنت
بطرح عليه سؤال مشابه ليك وكان في حاله
غضب يعني في الشارع العربي
هو قال الكلام ده بعدها بحوالي ثلاث اربع
شهور يعني كلام اخر 2010 تقريبا
وجدت الثورات الربيع العربي فيعني ما
اقدرش اتوقع اللي ممكن يحصل بعد عشر سنين
لكن الشرق الاوسط منطقه يعني سبحان الله
منطقه مسكونه موبوءه يعني انت عندك لما
تيجي تشوف بيقولوا دلوقتي اخر حاجه لما
كنت بتابع اخبار الزلزال يقول لك ان منطقه
الشرق الاوسط منطقه يعني تنشط فيها
الزلازل يعني احنا ناقصين الزلازل هي
منطقه تنشط فيها الزلازل هي اصلا موبوءه
من غير زلازل هي منطقه واحده من اكثر
المناطق تاثرا بموجات الحراره والجفاف لا
التغير المناخي هي منطقه موبوءه بحركات
متطرفه هي منطقه موبوءه بعدم استقرار
سياسي
منطقه موبوءه باطماع دول خارجيه لانها
منطقه سانتريل مركزيه فيها ثروات عندها
يعني
محاطه بالمجاري المائيه اللي هي
الشرايين الملاحه الدوليه
ما اقدرش اتنبا الحياه بعد عشر سنين في
ايه يا صديقي انه هي عاشت في وضع صعب
وعلى الارجح هتكون صعبه مره تشرشل قال
كلمه لطيفه بيقول هو كان بيتكلم على
العراق يعني لكن اللي ينطبق على العراق
ينطبق على غيره بيقول اللي بيتعامل مع
العراق كمان يجلس فوق بركان جاحد في الارث
كويت اسف بركان جاحد انجريت في الفولكينو
يعني ان انت تعيش فوق فولكينو ده خطر يكون
فولكينو يعني جاحد تعبير
ما رايك بالربط
بين زلزال تركيا ومشروع هارب مشروع هرب
يعني اللي هي التجارب اللي بيعملوها سرا
لا علم لي والله مستر يعني يقول لسيد على
طول انت شبهت الوضع في لبنان بوضع اليمن
وبعد كده قلت ان وضع اليمن مختلف ممكن
تشرح لنا مختلف ازاي وضع الايام للاقتصادي
ضروري اه طبعا انا اقصد اقول انه في
اللبنان وجه التشابه ان الاتنين بيعيشوا
ازمات عنيفه بس لبنان او وجه التشابه ان
الاتنين بلا حكومه مركزيه واضحه الفرق انه
لبنان في قوه واحده غالبه اللي هي على حزب
الله لكن تفضل انه يكون يعني تدير البلد
من خلال حكومه محل رضا الجميع
بمعنى انه حزب الله
عاوز يعيش عاوز ان البلد تحكم بتوافق
سياسي ولو سوري يكون هو الحاكم الاساسي مش
عاوز يدخل بدباباته ومدافعه في القصر لكن
هو عاوز يبقى هو القوه المسيطره وعاوز هو
يحرك المشهد بحكم قوته العسكريه ونفوده من
خلال حكومه يقبل بها الاخرين وبما ان
الاخرين انصرفوا عنه في الوقت الحالي ومش
قادرين يهزموه عسكريا ومش قادرين يهزموه
سياسيا وهو مش قادر يكون حكومه من غير
توافقهم في البلد فيها فوضى الفوضى دي
معناها ان الاقتصاد بينكمش زي الانسان
اللي عنده ربنا يشفي الجميع مرض الضمور
اللي هو جسمه بيضمر بيضعف
والناس بتتصرف ازاي انه مستواها المعيشي
ينحدر ان الناس تهاجر الى اخره
لكن هو كقوه رئيسيه بيحمي مصالحه بطريقته
يعني هو بمصادره اليمن الوضع فيه مش كده
الوضع احنا عندنا قوى لسه السلاح ساخن
وعندنا الحوثيين بتحاول تقريبا يعني تسيطر
على منطقه معينه في الوقت الحالي وقوه
اخرى بتحاول تزيحها حتى هذه اللحظه
الطرفين هم في حاله حرب وده مختلف عن
لبنان لكن وجه التشابه ان ما عندناش حكومه
واحده ما فيش حكومه كل واحد بيعيش تحت
حكومه مختلفه يعني حكومه الحوثيين اللي هي
ماذون ومحاصره وحكومه الشرعيه اللي تحتها
مجموعه حكومات وبالتالي اليمنيين عايشين
بدون حكومه واحده
مركزيه تقدر تدير ثروات البلد وازماته
لبنان عايش بدون حكومه واحده محل اجماع
تقدر تدير حكومات البلد
وازماتها ولكن كلا به ظروفه المختلفه
ليبيا نفس القصه ولكن برضو درفه مختلفه
عندها ثروات
قل اسمي عوض عبد الحميد
حاضر عوض عبد الحميد انا اسف لما كنتش قلت
اسمك بس انا مش فاهم يا صديقي انا اتشرف
ان انا اقول اسمك يا اخويا العزيز اسال
وانا تحت امرك
هل ممكن العرب يتحدوا جون ديفيد يعني ولا
اتحادهم اصلا يعني كان مطروح بشكل جاد
انما ممكن يتعاونوا يعني
لماذا تتعامل بريطانيا مع روسيا بشكل اكثر
عدائه من الولايات المتحده والله ده سؤال
جميل اخونا محمد حسن مش معناه ان الاسئله
الاخرى لم تكن جميله يعني بس هنقصد انه
كان شاغلني انا كمان
هي طبعا في يعني في حاجات يعني مفهومه او
مش مفهومه نقدر يعني
عارفين سبب تحركها اول سبب ان الحرب طبعا
بريطانيا واحده من الدول الكبيره هي صحيح
دوله من الحجم المتوسط ما هياش الولايات
المتحده ما هياش الصين ما هياش حتى روسيا
يعني
انما هي دوله كبيره وهي بالتالي صاحبه
ستاكس او مصالح في كل صراعه تقريبا في
العالم خصوصا ان كان في اوروبا ده واحد
اتنين هي كانت واحده من الدول الاساسيه
اللي راعت اتفاق استقلال اوكرانيا في اول
التسعينات
تلاته هي
طبعا يعني ده هي عاوزه دايما تكون
بعد انسحبها من
اللي هو
عاوزه تقول للاتحاد الاوروبي ان انا دوله
مهمه ما تنصرفش عني انا قادره على التاثير
في كل صراعي يهمك ويهم العالم وبالتالي
يتعاملوا معها لا يهملوها هي حريصه ان هي
تكون طرف او رقم صعب في كل الصراعات خصوصا
اذا كان في اوروبا لما في سبب رابع هي ان
الازمه اندلعت وهم كان عندهم ازمات داخليه
الراجل
رئيس الوزراء
[موسيقى]
من ذهني حكم الزهايمر
الرجل الشعر اللي هو دايما بيقول انا عندي
مشط بسرحش مين الرئيس الوزراء الاستقال
معلش حد يفكرني يا شباب
فرئيس الوزراء ثم جت
وزيره الخارجيه ثم جاء
رئيس الوزراء الحالي
هم كان عندهم ازمات داخليه حبوا الازمات
الداخليه المستمره خلال ثلاث وزراء برج
جونسون انا اسف رئيس الوزراء
وبالتالي كان عنده ازمه ازمه ان هو عنده
مشاكل في حزبه واتهمه بالكذب واتهمه يعني
بامور اخرى وانه كان عنده مشاكل مع يعني
داخليه كرئيس وزاره حب يصرف الانتباه عنك
كالعاده بانه يعلي صوته قوي في ازمه يعني
اللي هي الازمه الروسيه والاخرين رئيسيه
الوزراء الاخرين كانوا بيعانوا من نفس
المشكله وبالتالي برضه شغل الراي العام
بمشاكل خارجيه كان واحد من عوامل وليس كل
العوامل
حضرتك في امل ان حضرتك تعمل سلسله الحضاره
الصينيه اللي حضرتك وعدت بها قبل ذلك وان
حضرتك بتدور على واحد تستطيع ان تثق فيه
هو في امل اه بس انا برضو عشان اكون صادق
معك انت طلبت السلسله عن الاقتصاد على
فكره انا يبدو ان انا بعمل حاجه غلط انا
يجب ان انا اصححها واعتذر عنها انت لما حد
بيقترح على حاجه موضوع وبقول انا فعلا
عاوز اعمله انا بكون صادق والله بس صادق
زي ما بيقول كده المسيح عليه السلام النفس
راغبه والجسد ضعيف يعني انا قلت انا عاوز
اعمل حاجه عن نعومه مثلا انا بعشقه واشوف
ان انا لو عملت عليه حلقه
هتبقى حاجه عظيمه جدا وهتستفيد منها الناس
انما اللي بيحصل ان الحلقه الواحده بتاخد
وقت كتير جدا وده جزء من
الالموندهش ان انا انا سامع او يعني كمان
ماندو هو يعني بقى الخبير في الحاجات ديت
اللي هو بيشرف على قنوات كتيره ان في ناس
بيعملوا حلقه كل يوم وسامع ان في ناس
بيعملوا من ماندو يعني بيقول لي ان في ناس
بيعملوا حلقتين وتلاته في اليوم
يعني ممكن ما اعرفش هم بيعملوا ايه بس
الواضح ان هو مثلا بيجيب مقال يقراها او
كذا بس علشان تعمل حاجه وتنزل فيها جهد
وتاثلها وتحط براجع وتتاكد ان المعلومه
معلومه جيده
وتعملها زي ما اتعلمنا كصحفيين صغيرين ان
اي معلومه
علشان هي مش معلنه يعني عاوز تعرف معلومه
لازم تتوثق على الاقل من على الاقل من
مصدرين مختلفين ويكون الكلام منطقي ويكون
المصدر له علاقه مسالش واحد مثلا
في وزاره الدفاع المغربيه عن معلومه
بيقولها مثلا خاصه باسبانيا الا اذا كان
ده صله يعني فالامور دي بتاخد وقت كتير
فسامحوني انا ببقى عاوز لكن التاكس تايم
بتاخد وقت طويل من في المستقبل هبقى متحفظ
في اجابتي واقول عندما يسمح الوقت وتعليقا
على سؤالك لا انا اجد صعوبه في الحصول على
مصادر واساتذه عندهم استعداد انه
يدوا محتوى كاد ما يكونش انشائي ويكون فيه
جهد ويكون مكثف عمليه سهله يعني
واللي يعرف حد يقول لي عليه واهلا وسهلا
به سواء في هذا المجال او في غيره
مساء الخير سيد يا ريت لو يتوفر محتوى
القلعه على منصات البودكاست انا حاسس انها
صعبه
بيقول لي شغالين في الموضوع بيقول لي
شغالين بس انا يعني
برضو علشان ده بيبقىش وعد هم العمليه
مرتبطه بحاجات تانيه هم اولا في الشركه
اللي بتنتج الحلقات ديت هم يقدروا
يعني يقدروا يحصلوا على عائد عن طريق
يوتيوب لانه هم عندهم في تكلفه يعني في
مقر في مكان يعني مكلف في فريق عمل
في حاجات كتيره فهما عاوزين برضو مفيش حد
بيقدم خصوصا ان انا برفض الاعلانات يعني
لو خدتوا بالكم انا بيجي لي عروض يقول لي
تعالى خد برعايه كذا الحاجه الوحيده اللي
ممكن تقبل انه والله حد عاوز يقول في اول
البرنامج برعايه اذا كانت شركه محترمه
اوكي لكن انا ما بعملش ما بقولش والله انا
النهارده بفكركم بانه احنا معنا النهارده
تليفون كذا ولا ما بعملش ده برفوض
وبالتالي لا يوجد عائد على القناه اللي
فيها مجموعه من الشباب المحترمين وفريق مش
صغير يعني الا العائد من الاعلانات اللي
بيقدمه يوتيوب في حاجه تانيه موجوده لا
تقدم اي عائد وبالتالي الناس دي هتبقى
عندها مشكله لان لازم يكون في عائد
بس هو في ناس بيسمعوه يعني انا شخصيا بسمع
نفسي لما اكون عاوز او حد بسمعه كانه يعني
ما بتفرجش يعني
هم حابين الحاجات دي تبقى اوديو هو ماندو
هنا بيسال مش عارف اذا كنت سمعت صوته ولا
لا بس بيقول لك يعني انت حابب انه يكون
صوت ده فيه ميزه عشان تسمعه في العربيه
مثلا
اه بيتهيا لي معظمهم بيقول كده بس هو لسه
هيرد عليا يعني ما انت عندك الاسئله ساعه
تشوف الرد اكتر مني السلام عليكم نريد
حلقه تنصحني بايه لو عايزه لاسراء اقرا عن
الاسباب الحقيقيه وراء التاخر العربي
والصراع الفكري للماجستير وابداء وابدا
ازاي ده سؤال عميق قوي يا اسراء اسباب
الحقيقيه وراء التاخر العربي طب مش مش
موضوعات الماجستير والحاجات دي يا اسراء
بيكون مثلا فكره محدده موضوع كبير يعني
احنا احنا العرب المنطقه العربيه كلها
والتاخر كله
بس انا عاوز اقول لك على حاجه في كتاب
مهتمين بقضايا النهضه انا ما اعرفش انت من
اللهجه اللي انت كاتبه بها اعتقد ان انت
مصريه لو اتكلمتي الدكتور
بهاء الدين عرجون اللي شرفني مره هنا هو
مشغول بالقضيه دي جدا وعنده كتاب لم يخرجه
بعد بس انا اظن ان هو ممكن يساعدك في ناس
بيسميهم النهضهويين في اكتر من دوله عربيه
يعني مهتمين بالاجابه على سؤالك ديت بس
اللي انا يعني
اعرفه جاب زين على طول الاستاذ والصديق
الدكتور بهيه الدين عربون استاذ
المركبات الفضائيه
في جامعه القاهره كليه هندسه وهو كان
شرفني مره هنا مرتين انما هو مهتم بالقضيه
ديت لان هو دائما مهتم بتاريخ العلم وهذه
القضيه
يبقى انت هتحددي الفكره اكتر شويه هل يمكن
ده عمر بيسال هل يمكن تقسيم اوكرانيا
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده اه طبعا ممكن
جدا ما ده اللي احنا كنا بنقوله في اول
حلقه ان هي ممكن تبقى عندنا اوكرانيا زي
شبه الجزيره الكوريه كده
عندنا كوريا الشماليه وكوريا الجنوبيه
وبالتالي يبقى عندنا
اوكرانيا الشرقيه تحت السيطره الروسيه
اوكرانيا الغربيه تحت السيطره الغربيه
يعني يعني هي غربيه جيوغرافيك لي وغربيه
تحت سيطره الغرب
اخونا عادل الجابري بيقول استاذ سيد مريدي
حلقه عن الخلاف الروسي الغربي ولماذا
روسيا دائما في خلاف معهم
مع العلم انها دوله اوروبيه هي نفس السؤال
ده موضوع حلقه اظن بفضل الله يعني ان انا
اتوفقت في الاجابه عليها بيحكي قصه الصراع
الابدي بين روسيا وبين الولايات المتحده
بين قصير الغرب موجوده على القناه لو
حضرتك بدلت جهد شويه هتلاقيها هي بس طبعا
طريقه البحث في القناه ان انت احيانا لو
هي مثلا مكتوبه الف عليه همزه فلو كتبت
مثلا مثلا الولايات
مش مثل اسباب فلو هي كانت مكتوبه
بهمزه فمش يظهر لك فانت دور بكذا طريقه عن
روسيا عن الصراع الروسي الامريكي هتلاقيها
موجوده وكانت حلقه اظن فيها كل التفاصيل
يعني
واذا لم تجدها ابعث لي رساله على الصفحه
العامه على الفيسبوك هبعت لك الحلقه
واحنا قدامنا كتير يا
لان الناس في اسئله كتير
نتمنى حلقه تتحدث فيه عن التامين في مصر
بعد ثوره الضباط الاحرار واثار على
الاقتصاد على الدوله حتى اليوم
مش عارف تفتكر حد هيهتم بها يا صديقنا
تحيه طيبه استاذ لماذا تم لماذا تصعيد
لمتى صعيد الجزائر ضد المغرب وهناك قطع
علاقات وتهديد بالحرب مقارنه نتمنى حلقه
عن هذا التصعيد الخطير لا ده في اكثر من
حلقه مش حلقه واحده يعني لو بتتكلم عن
اسباب الخلاف ماديه عامله زي السؤال اللي
كان موجود شويه انا دايما في خلاف روسي
غربي واللي انا بقول فيه حلقه كامله عليه
هو دايما في التنافس والصراع ما بين
الجزائر والمغرب وبرضو في حلقه كامله عن
القصه دي ولكن الاجابه السريعه اللي ممكن
تساعدني في فهم الصراع ما بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده الابدي وما بين المغرب
والجزائر هو المبدا اللي موجود في
العلاقات الدوليه اللي بيسموه
توازن القوه الكلمه دي دمها تقيل انا بفكر
يعني بفضل اقول الخوف هي كلمه واحده انت
بتبقى دولتين الدول بتتصرف زي البني ادمين
انت دولتين ادي الجزائر وادي المغرب الدول
دايما عندها شعور بالخوف من جيرانها مثلا
الجزائر اذا شافت المغرب
ده مثل حقيقي بالمناسبه انه الجزائر شافت
المغرب
بتعمل علاقات مع اسرائيل واسرائيل يعني
هتديها اسلحه متطوره فتبتدي على طول تفكر
ان هي تزود مخزونها من السلاح وتجيب من
اصدقائها الروس والصينيين وبدات تجيب
خمسه وتلاتين ودي طياره قويه واسلحه اخرى
المغرب حست بالقلق فابت بتطلب من الولايات
المتحده انا عاوزه اف 35 اسف اف ايه اه اف
خمسه وتلاتين الاكثر تطورا
الجزائر تشعر ان ده هيبقى في غير صالحه
فتطلب سخوي سبعه وخمسين وهكذا يعني فالقصه
ان الدول بتخاف هو ده اللي هو بيسموه
واللي انا بسميه الخوف
انك دوله تحاول تقوي نفسها حتى لو ما
عندهاش نيه ان هي تعتدي على دوله اخرى
الدول الجيران بتقلق تبتدي تتزود هي كمان
بالتحالف مع دول اخرى بالتسلح فالدوله
التانيه تشعر بالقلق وندخل في فيديو
السيركل سيركل اللي بيسموها بقى ايه
او يعني معضله الامن انا ما عنديش ثقه فيك
فانا وهكذا يعني
وبعدين دول في الخلافات من من منتصف
الستينات يا صديقي مش جديد الكلام
اخونا اد معرفش ايه انت سايب كل مشاكل مصر
وبتتكلم عن مواضيع ما لكش دخل فيها فيهم
الثقافه والعلم دون شجاعه مش فاهم حاجه
يعني انت احلف والله القران يعني انا ما
قلتش ان في عقد بيني وبين الناس ان انا
بتكلم عن مصر يعني ده مش موجود انت انا
عارف ان انت مهتم بالشارع المصري على عيني
وراسي بس هي مش كل اللي بيتفرجوا علينا
مصريين يعني وانا لما عملت القناه كان في
ذهن ان انا بتكلم على الشان الدولي ومكتوب
على القناه من بره كده لو رجعت هذه قناه
مهتمه بالعلاقات الدوليه العلاقات الدوليه
يعني دوله بدوله مش معقوله العلاقات
الدوليه يعني القضيه البصريه المصريه يعني
وبعدين انت بتقول لي مش عاوزه تشجعها ما
هي مفهوم انا بحاول افهم سؤالك ما هي
مفهوم الشجاعه ان انا اقول ان الحكومه
فاشله وان الرئيس فاشل ده ردح مش
وبعدين لو انت عاوز النوع ده من المواد
لما انت عندك قنوات كثيره ما في قنوات
كثيره موجوده في اظن في لندن دلوقتي وكانت
موجوده في تركيا لفتره طويله وكل يوم
بيشتم الحكومه استمتع واستماعهم يعني اذا
كان ده
هيبسطك روح وكل بلد موجود في قنوات بتقدم
النوع ده قنوات بتشتم السلطه اللي موجوده
في امارات في المغرب في الجزائر في
السعوديه في الكويت فاستمتع بهم بس انت
احنا انا ما بقدمش هذا النوع حتى لو انا
النهارده سافرت الاسكيم واصبحت انا مش
هقدم هذا النوع النوع ده ان في ناس بتقدمه
وبتستفيد منه وبتستمتع به ولكن انا بقدم
هذا الماده اللي هي موجود فيه حوالي 500
حلقه منهم بيحاول فهم سلوك الدول وبس
اشكرك عموما على الملحوظه يعني اللي انا
حاولت استنتج معناها حضرتك هل في امل
عملناها كيف متى
اخونا
انا اسف فقط في قرايه الاسم مساء الخير
استاذ جبايل تحياتي لخال ما هو وضع
الاكراد في ظل الاحداث الراهنه
فين بقى انت عندك في سوريا
هم دلوقتي قدام تحدي جديد
يعني الزلزال ده يحمل لهم مؤقتا هم بقول
ليه مؤقتا على المستوى البعيد هم تحت ضغط
عنيف جدا انه لا تركيا ولا سوريا ولا
العراق ولا ايران هيسمحوا بان هو يكون
فكره ان كل دوله مستقله اما ان هو يستمتع
بحياه ومواطنه هيبقى زيه زي المواطن
العادي تقريبا يعني لانه يعني بمعايير
بمعايير منطقه الشرق الاوسط يعني انما لو
تقصد ان هو يحصل على اكثر من ذلك ده هيكون
صعب في سوريا في منطقه حكم ذاتي وهو ممكن
الظروف دلوقتي
هتخليه يتنفس مش هيكون في غزو تركي لشمال
سوريا
الحكومه بشار هتكون تحت ضغط عنيف ممكن هم
ظروفهم اللي كمان ساعدتهم بانه الزلزال ما
ضربش بشكل عنيف شمال شرق ممكن غرفه تبقى
احسن في الفتره اللي جايه
في العراق هم ظروفهم احسن بكتير من اي
دوله اخرى
في تركيا
يعني زي ما انت عارف كده انه ازلون جهاز
ان انت ما تقولش اي حاجه تتعلق بفكره
الاستقلال او او الانفصال او مطالب خاصه
فانت عايش كويس ما فيش مشاكل يعني
السلام عليكم نريد حلقه قلنا
عاوزين حلقه عن حل الازمه الاقتصاديه في
مصر مع الاستاذ هاني
حاضر
هل تتوقع ان يكون هناك دور مهم للصين في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ما هي لها دور
مهمه يا صديقي وبتلعبه من الاول بس يعني
هي
وبالمناسبه بره التانيه في يعني من شهر
مارس وانا عامل حلقه عن موقف الصين من
الحرب هي وقع تحت اعتبارات كثيره قوي
المفروض ان هي ما تدعمش روسيا لان اللي
عملته روسيا يمثل احراج للصين
قضيه مركزيه للصين ان هي عندها تايوان
اللي هي بتقول دي جزء مني وهو منفصل عني
ولازم يعود الي
وبالتالي لو حصل انه الولايات المتحده
انه
يعني في وجهه تشابه هنا انه دلوقتي روسيا
بتقول ايه
انه انا هدخل هنا اوكرانيا وهغزوها
دفاعا او هدخل الحرب دفاعا عن الاقليات
الروسيه اللي بتقول انا مش عاوزه ابقى جزء
من
جزء من اوكرانيا ده معناها انه لما تبارك
الصين هذا الكلام واعلاء
واعترفت باستقلال جمهوريتي الدومباس معنى
كده ان الصين لا وافد على الكلام ده وهي
لم توافق ان هي تبارك ان الولايات المتحده
تدخل تايوان وتقول احنا بندعم استقلالها
وضد الصين في تناقض الصين رفض الموقف
الروسي نظريا لكن عمليا هي عارفه انه عدد
حلفائها اللي بمستوى روسيا في اي صراعم
قائم وقد يكون قريب جدا مع الغرب مش قطار
وبالتالي هي بتظل تدعم روسيا مش لان هي
مؤمنه بموقفها في اوكرانيا ولكن لان هي
مؤمنه باهميتها ليها
تكلم عن الايه عن السيسي سيبك انت ده نفس
الاستاذ اصبحت الشعوب العربيه متعاطفه مع
الافكار المتطرفه ما جعل الديكتاتوريين
يسرقون انفسهم متعاطفه مع الافكار
المتطرفه
من يحمل حريه والعلمانيه وانهم يحكمون
متطرفين ما رايك معلش حاولوا اقرا تاني
مروان بتقول اصبحت الشعوب العربيه متعاطفه
مع الافكار المتطرفه ما جعل الديكتاتوريين
يسوقون انفسهم على انهم من يحمون الحريه
والعلمانيه والله انا كنت شايف كده بس انا
في بيتهيالي بعد فتره يعني
ان العمليه يعني مش بالبساطه كده يعني
احنا قاسين على نفسنا قوي في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط احنا
يعني احنا مش استثناء قوي من العالم يعني
يعني حتى الواكسه جت للدول اللي هي
المتقدمه فكره ان انت تبقى دوله
ديمقراطيه ليبراليه ويبقى عندك مثلا
الحقوق العظيمه جدا في تفعيل القانون زي
بريطانيا وزي فرنسا وزي المانيا على الاقل
يعني
لغايه دلوقتي يعني حتى لو حصل تراجع
وانتكاسه لكن الدول دي عددها صغير جدا
واستثناء لكن معظم دول العالم مش بنفس
الدرجه دي اللي انت تقدر تستمتع فيها
برفائق اقتصاديه وتقدر تستمتع فيها بحكم
قانون وتقدر تستمتع فيها بقدره على انه
صوتك يعمل فارق كبير
المنطقه الشرق الاوسط ما هياش استثنائي
يعني لكن هي ممكن تبقى زي الدول ديت
ممكن بس بعد 100 سنه مثلا او حاجه يعني
اذا بدات تطور يحصل هم كمان احتاجوا 200
300 سنه مش قصدي اسخر والله بس بتكلم جد
يعني يعني ايطاليا وكل دول اوروبا دول
اخدوا بناء الدوله دي اخذت مئات السنين
انت بتقول ردا على سؤالك عشان ما اكونش
توهتك ان هم ديكتاتوري بيسوق لنفسه انه
بيحمي نفسه من العلميه تجاه متطرفين انا
اقول لك اجابه يعني انه اي دوله او مش اي
دوله اي معظم الدول ومنها دول منطقه الشرق
الاوسط دائما بيكون عندك المؤسسات
التقليديه يعني عندك العراق سوريا مثلا
هتلاقي القبيله والعشيره هتلاقي بلد زي
مصر دي ما عندهاش العشيره ولكن عندها
الجامعات الدينيه اذا كان ازهر اذا كان
اخواني اذا كانت جامعات سلفيه وعندهم
الجيش فدائما هذه هي القصه يعني فطبيعي
انه الدول اللي هي هت فيها جماعات دينيه
في مقابل مؤسسات عسكريه هيبقى تقريبا كده
العلمانيين ولو انهم مش علمانين قوي في
مواجهه الجامعات الدينيه اللي هي مش دينيه
قوي والسلطه هي القاسم المشترك هي المطمع
المشترك ما بين الاتنين
كيف كان سيكون شكل مصر استمرت تحت الملكيه
ده واحد من الناس هذا يا صديقي اسئله
بتبقى يعني
عاوزه تامل كبير جدا
يعني لا قدره لي عليها ماذا لو عاوزه
افتراض عاوز تفكر كثير ماذا لو استمر
الحكم الملكي في العراق استمر الحكم
الملكي في مصر استمر يعني عاوزه
[موسيقى]
عاوزه تفكر وتحط سيناريوهات يعني اسعد
الله اوقاتك اليس من المفروض ان على الدول
العربيه وخاصه الغنيه انتهب ان تهب وتنجد
اخوتهم من شعب سوريا المنكوب تحيه كبيره
لمصر والجزائر وتونس وليبيا والامارات
وايران والعراق الابي تحيه لك ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك بس انا اعتقد ان دول كتيره راحت
يعني انا في حدود معلوماتي ان الدول حتى
اللي عندها امكانيات بسيطه راحت وقدمت
مساعدات
شكرا استاذ سيد عن حلقه عن الاقتصاد لمن
تتعامل بها على العراقي يطبع مع اسرائيل
ده في قانون في العراق بيمنعهم من التطبيع
ما اعتقدش ان الطبيه مع اسرائيل اولويه
خالص عند اي حكومه عراقيه دلوقتي ولا
لسنوات يعني
لماذا لا يتم تسليط الضوء على ما تعنيه
الاقليات غير المسلمه في الشرق الاوسط من
العنصريه ومعامله سيئه ومعالتهم ومعاملتهم
على انهم مواطنين
درجه تانيه اخونا هاني رمزي العراقي والله
عندك حق لا يتم تسليط الضوء لانه ليس
اولويه يعني لانه انت الناس اللي بيتكلموا
على الاقليه دول
لازم هم يعني يكون يعني الناس ابتدت تتكلم
عن حقوق الانسان فين في الغرب لما هو
ابتدى ياخد مسافه كتيره استقر الحكم بقى
في طبقه متوسطه متعلمه مرتاحه بتفكر في
حقوق الاقليات الاخرى بتفكر في حقوق
المهاجرين يعني اشكال مختلفه من الحقوق
حتى مش حقوق الانسان حقوق غير الانسان
يعني لكن لما بكون دوله مضطربه جدا
والاوضاع فيها صعبه بيكون دائما اضعف يعني
الحلقه الضعيفه هي الاقليات للاسف الشديد
انت عندك يعني مستوى تعليم منخفض انت
بتتكلم على مستوى اقتصادي متراجع بتتكلم
على تطرف بتكلم على عدم استقرار سياسي مش
دي البيئه اللي ممكن يكون فيها احترام
حقوق الاقليات يعني اولويه
انا هستاذنكم نقف في الساعه تسعه ونص
اخويا احكي لنا على تونس خويا طيب استاذنك
لو تحدد السؤال صديقي محمد وانا تحت امرك
لو كنت اعرف الاجابه هقول
هل ممكن
ازاي اصبحت الصين في 2005 اكبر مصدر للسلع
في العالم في الوقت ده الصين ما كانتش
اقتصاد قوي انا اعتقد السؤال ده متكرر عبد
الرحمن السويفي هقراه تاني كده زي الصين
اصبحت في 2005 اكبر مصدر للصلع في العالم
وفي الوقت ده الصين ما كانتش اقتصاد قوي
يعني انا اللي انا فاهمه ان انت عاوز تقول
ازاي بقت هي لها نصيب كبير في التجاره
العالميه وما كانتش اقتصاد قويه هي الصين
بدات كالاتي
من بعد سنه 49 لغايه سنه يعني بعد بعد
انتهاء الحرب الاهليه في الصين سنه 49
وانتصار الحزب الشيوعي على القوميين اللي
هم استقروا في تايوان وبدات مشكله تايوان
لغايه سنه 78 وهم بيعملوا محاولات مستميته
في ان هم يكونوا دوله متطوره وكان فشل ورا
فشل ورا فشل
لكن كان في محاولات اتبنى عليها بعد كده
78 بدات فكره الانفتاح على العالم ان احنا
ناخد
الاحلامنا وثقافتنا فكره الشيوعيه او
الاشتراكيه ولكن على الطريق الصينيه ان
احنا ننفتح على العالم وندي مساحه اكبر
للقطاع الخاص ونبتدي ناخد افكار جديده
وبداوا يعملوا تطور تدريجي وكانت دوله
اقتصادها بسيط جدا بتتكلم على حوالي يعني
مثلا حوالي يعني ارقام صغيره انا اظن في
نتكلم على يعني مئات المليارات يعني رقم
مواشي ضخم جدا يعني مثلا في حدود
التريليون ولا حاجه
ترليون بالنسبه لبلد معدي المليار نسمه ده
رقم صغير بعدين بدات هي
تسوق لنفسها على انها مصنع العالم
الولايات المتحده كانت مستفيده من القصه
دي على صعيدين ان هي تكسب هذا البلد
الكبير جدا في صفها بعيدا عن الاتحاد
السوفيتي اللي كان في ايامه الاخيره
وتستفيد منه كصوت كبير وتستفيد منه
كاستقرار وبالتالي بدات هي تشجعها على ان
هي تبقى متفوقه اقتصاديا وتنقل لها
استثمارات ولا تمانع في ان هي تاخد
التكنولوجيا الغربيه البسيطه اللي مش
معقده وساعده الصين على الدخول في منظمه
التجاره العالميه
بدات الصين تدريجيا بالاستثمارات الغربيه
الكبيره اللي كانت مستفيده سبب اضافه
نسيته ان هم بيروحوا هناك رجال الاعمال
فبدل ما بيدفع للعامل الامريكي مثلا وقتها
على ما اذكر يعني حد ادنى 15 دولار في
الساعه ممكن يدفع له 15 دولار دول في
الاسبوع
فحققوا ثروات ضخمه جدا الصينيين مستفيدين
الغرب مستفيد
فكانتيشن بدات المساله يحصل فيها تغيير في
طبعا بالمعنى ده في المرحله ديت من منتصف
من اواخر السبعينات واوائل التامينات لما
وصلنا
لالفين 2010 و205 زي ما انت بتقول بقت هي
المصنع العالم وبالتالي اكبر مصدر للعالم
للسلع اللي هي عباره عن استثمارات المانيه
وفارسيه وامريكيه
ومن دول اخرى موجوده في هذا المصنع الضخم
فهكذا بدا يتضخم الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لها بدات بقى الخلافه الاكبر في حاجتين او
خلينا عشان انت بتكلم على الاقتصاد ان هي
بدات تطمح في انها تنتقل من ان هي مصنع
لتكنولوجيات عاديه المنسوجات
الاركونديشنز حاجات كده يعني او السيارات
العاديه الى الدخول في التكنولوجيات
الحرجه اللي الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
يتمنوا ان تظل احتكارا عليها وبدا هنا
صعود الصين يتضح اللي وبدات الولايات
المتحده تنظر لها على انها منافس وليس
سوقا كبيرا يمكن ان يكون امتدادا
لمنتجاتها
[موسيقى]
لان في الاسلام طاعه ولي الامر السلطان
يعني عفوا لم افهم هل يمكن ادخال
المساعدات
الى مناطق سيطره المعارضه للزلزال مباشره
بدون العبور عبر مناطق سيطره النظام وما
فيش غير معبر الهواء انت لو فتحت الخريطه
هتلاقي كان في مجموعه من المعابر معبر في
اقصى الشرق مع الحدود انا مش قادر افتكر
اسمه يعني
والروميس اظن في الجنوب والسلام فوق كده
مع تركيا كل دول تعطلوا يعني ولها قصه
طويله يعني انما الامم المتحده كانت اقرت
بسبب نزاع القوى الكبيره في مجلس الامن
الاونلي تسالوني عليه واستقروا في النهايه
انه باب الهوى هو الباب الوحيد اللي يدخل
منه من تركيا يعني ناس يبعتوا لمساعدات
لتركيا ومن تركيا يدخل على باب الهواء انت
عاوز بقى تنزل على المطارات السوريه وتنزل
بضايعك والنظام هو يتصرف من الناس مش
عاوزين يتعاملوا مع النظام امريكا مش
عاوزه الاتحاد الاوروبي مش عاوز
في دول عاوزه وخايفه من العقوبات
الامريكيه لكن المشكله كمان ان باب الهوى
الان
معطل لانه الزلزال اتلف الطريق الرئيس
الذي يؤدي اليه انا هستاذنكم واقف عند
الدقيقه
30 انا عارف ان في اسئله كتيره لكن ان شاء
الله هناخد كمان سؤالين ونستانف الاسبوع
المره المقبله باذن الله
حضرتك هل في امل
سيد جبيل اتمنى تجاوبني عن سؤال ان انا
تعبنا من الاقتصاد هل وضع المصريين يتحسن
الاقتصاديا قريبا لاننا تعبنا لا انا مش
شايف انه يكون فيه ما فيش مؤشرات بتقول ان
في تحسن درامي خلال شهور
يعني اذا كنت بتتكلم على فرص عمل كبيره
اذا كنت بتتكلم على انخفاض كبير في
الاسعار انا ما فيش مؤشرات لكن ممكن يبقى
في مؤشرات الا تتدهور الاوضاع اكثر من ذلك
في ظل الوضع انا قلت السؤال ده هل برايك
ظاهره الكتائب في الضفه الغربيه ستلعب
دورا ما تنساش كمان انت بتتكلم على
الاقتصاد ما انت بس انت مصري دي ما انتاش
عايش لوحدك انا مش عارف ليه كل الاسئله
الاقتصاديه خاصه بمصر يعني
انت مش عايش لوحدك ما انت عندك يعني يعني
اذا تجاوزت مصر اذا تجاوزت تونس اذا
تجاوزت المنطقه كلها تجد انه السؤال اللي
جاوبونا في اول الحلقه الركود اللي للاسف
العالم قد يدلف اليه المتاعب الاقتصاديه
في كل مكان يعني لكن طبعا بتزيد حدتها لما
يكون البلد اصلا البلد فقير او مش غني انا
اسف ان انا سوف اتوقف يعني عند هذا القدر
احنا عندنا اسئله تانيه كتير
ماذا عن الازمه المغربيه الفرنسيه العميقه
في مجالات عديده واتجاه المغرب
للبراغماتيه والواقعيه في السياسه الخارجي
بيتكلم عن السياسه المغربيه انا انا اقول
لك فيما يتعلق لو انت انا معرفش اذا حضرتك
مغربي ولا يعني جنسيتك اخرى بس انت لو
عاوز بتتكلم على السياسه الخارجيه
المغربيه طبعا الاسهل منظور ان انت تفهم
منه اساسا المغربيه هي موقف اي دوله
خارجيه من قضيه الصحراء قضيه الصحراء هي
القضيه المركزيه للسياسه الخارجيه
المغربيه هل في قضايا اخرى طبعا ما هو انت
سياسه الخارجيه ديت يعني هي بتحاول ان هي
تحافظ على مصالح البلد اقتصاديا وامنيا
الى اخره يعني
ولكن القضيه المركزيه اللي ممكن تفهم منها
كتير من السياسه الخارجيه المغربيه هي
موقع هي القضيه الصحراء
اي دوله بتؤيد المغرب في احكام سيطرتها
على الصحراء باعتبارها ارضا مغربيه فهي
دوله صديقه وتتعاون معها اي دوله تنازعها
في هذا الامر فهي بتبقى دوله غير صديقه
على الاقل كتير بقى ولانه احد الخلافات
الرئيسيه احد الاسباب الرئيسيه للخلاف بين
المغرب والجزائر هي موقف الجزائر المختلف
اللي شايف انه
الصحراء ليست ارضا مغربيه ولازم يكون في
استفتاء وقصه طبعا قلناها في اكتر من مكان
وعليه فان المغرب اللي بيشعر بضروره يعني
احكام سيطرته على الصحراء وضروره القضاء
على اي مقاومه من جانب الصحراويين وضروره
قطع الطريق على اي مساعدات جزائريه
للصحراويين في هذا الصدد واللي بينه توتر
مع الجزائر تقدر تفهم منه قضايا كتير بقى
في اداره علاقته مثلا
القصه الاهم بالنسبه لهم انه لما قالوا
لاداره ترامب احنا عاوزين نكون تعملوا
سابقه سابقه عمر امريكا ما كانت عملتها
قبل كده ان انتم تعترفوا بانه الصحراء هي
ارض مغربيه قالوا لهم بشرط ان انتم تطبعوا
مع اسرائيل قالوا لهم اهلا وسهلا
فساءت وتدهورت العلاقه اكتر مع الجزائر
وهكذا
العلاقات مع الفرنسيين قصه يطول شرحها بس
هستاذنك ان ممكن نتحدث عنها في وقت لاحق
ولان انا قلت معلش انا اسف انا كنت يعني
وعدت بعض الاصدقاء ان انا اقف عند الدقيقه
يعني تسعه وتلاتين
لان في بعض قالوا لما بكون كبيره جدا ما
بنقدرش نشوف الحلقه لاحقا يعني فانا انا
بشكركم جدا جدا وبعتذر مره اخرى على عدد
الاسئله الكبير اللي انا ما جاوبتش عليه
ان شاء الله في الحلقه المقبله انا نتناول
عدد اكبر من الاسئله
وربنا يسعد يومكم ويسعد ليلتكم وكل ايامكم
ان شاء الله اشكركم والى لقاء